hi my name is Leland I'm one of the user
experience designers on Android and one
of the things I like about the Android
browser is it does a lot of things I
could do on my desktop browser I want to
show you some of them so one of the
things I like about the Android browser
is I could play YouTube videos directly
from webpages so here I am on Google
News and I'm gonna click on a YouTube
video and here we go goes right into the
YouTube app and I could watch my videos
video so another cool thing is I could
save photos right to my phone so here's
a photo that my friend posted I want to
save it so I'm just gonna long press on
the photo hit save image and it's going
to download so while I wait for it to
download just go click open it and it
goes right into the photo gallery so
when the photo guy I could do whatever I
want but you know one thing I love is
that like right from the photo gallery I
can go and save it right as a wallpaper
there we go and there it is pretty cool
so the last thing I want to show you is
downloading mp3s one of the things I
like to do is follow one of my favorite
radio shows the host post mp3s so all I
have to do is download them right from
his website and what happens is I don't
have to wait and watch it download I
could just go back and browse the rest
of the page oh so I noticed that the
Downloads done because the notification
part blinked so I'm just going to go to
the notification bar
and see that download is complete just
click on the file there we go it could
start listening to my favorite radio
show